c'était le match de la peur ce dimanche
14 janvier les Versaillais
avant-derniers de la poule 8 de fééral 2
recevaient le dernier plusousanné tout a
mal commencé pour les ivlinois dépassé
en début de match il concède deux essais
mais versaill se reprend inscrit un
essai et arrive à égaliser avant la
mi-temps le score à la pause 10
partout de pas virer avec du retard au
point à la mi-temps c'est important
mentalement parce que c'est là où on
s'évite un doute trop important dans les
vestiaires en seconde période versaill
accélère et arrive à trouver des brèches
dans la défense de plusousané il
remporte la rencontre 24 à 20 malgré
quelques frayeurs en fin de match on
était quand même sur un cycle de SEP
défaites d'affilé et mine de rien c'est
quelque chose qui est très présent
mentalement essayer de se sortir de
cette spirale négative c'est très dur et
je pense qu'on retiendra surtout
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir réussi à
briser cette spirale et de de gagner
tout simplement de gagner et de
retrouver le goût de la victoire
aujourd'hui oui c'est respirable mais
bon le le le job est fait la victoire
est là et ça nous fait souffler un petit
peu grâce à cette victoire les
Versaillais peuvent respirer au
classement ils sortent de la zone de
relégation et se retrouvent à la 8e
place de leur poule de fédéral 2
l'équipe flirte toujours avec la
relégation aujourd'hui c'est respirable
parce que c'est des matchs de maintien
c'est des matchs du bas de tableau il va
falloir être fort mentalement avec des
équipes qui forcément sont sont un petit
peu fragilisé comme nous prochain match
pour les Versaillais ce dimanche 21
janvier les joueurs de la cité royale
joueront un derby sulfureux sur le
terrain de plaisir le match est
programmé à 15h15 une victoire permettra
à Versailles de s'installer en milieu de
classement